[Music]
emma watson and amanda seyfried victims
of yet another photo hat a spokesperson
for Emma tells ET that pictures of the
Beauty and the Beast are trying on
clothes during a fitting were stolen
from her phone and leaked online the rep
makes it clear she isn't nude in them
but they are seeking legal action you'll
recall in 2014 mo was threatened with
another private photo leaked she opened
up about the hoax at a Facebook event in
2015 quote I knew the pictures didn't
exist meanwhile Amanda ciphers lawyer is
demanding new pics of her that
apparently do exist be taken down from
the website celeb jihad immediately
according to the letter obtained by TMZ
the photos include intimate moments with
the actresses ex-boyfriend
Amanda's lawyer is demanding the website
immediately removed the images from
their site and that they preserve any
evidence related to this leaked et has
reached out to Amanda's rep for comment
as well as her attorney someone who is
speaking out Mischa Barton Mischa claims
she's been a victim of revenge porn
the actress held a press conference
Wednesday with her lawyer Lisa bloom
she says sexually explicit images of
herself were secretly recorded and are
now being shopped around this is a
painful situation and my absolute worst
fear was realized
[Music]